you've been doing intuition for a while
now it's kind of a persistent a sign to
become the rhythm we've been expanding
through a whole bunch of different
functions to see how it works and we
keep on referring back to
differentiation how are they connected
to each other now I know it's really
boring but when you learn terminology
and notation it's really powerful
because it lets you describe things and
distinguish between different things
which are very abstract which you
wouldn't be able to distinguish between
otherwise we'll describe really so
before we move on and talk about this I
just want to remember what are all these
pieces called they all have names
okay there's lots of little pieces here
simple instance the left-hand side and
the right-hand side each have the whole
thing for left hands behold it inside
the hole right hand side they each have
a name
remember this one starts with an all
right and this one starts with the peach
okay so this is an integral by the way
in this case it's not just any kind of
integral it's uh it's a definite
integral because I actually have
boundaries
it could be indefinite if I took the
month what about the right hand side
it's a primitive or a primitive function
really funny you know everything here
almost everything theories functions to
kind of get second okay that's what the
big pieces are there's a few more
specific pieces you got this thing
you've got this thing one of these calls
let's start with the right hand side for
easy one is that it's the constant
motion any constant it's the way
integrating so it's the constant of
integration
okay what about this a to be business
it's that you can either comment your
upper and all amounts or that's sort of
a catch-all phrase because sometimes
actually you know if you go ahead and
I'm you'll find that you can integrate
not just between two two values you can
integrate over an entire domain so you
could just say D for domain so in that
case you wouldn't really call them upper
and lower bounds you would call it this
is more general domain of integration
finally before I leave off this this
side the actual sign of integration was
its it was it's a it's an S but it's not
Sigma why is it a sigma cuz cuz C mu is
already taken that's seriously wife but
okay said Sigma which is the Greek
letter that we have equipment test
that's why s why not five for
integration looks good because the
strict out I would just look with there
s destroyed for some yeah because
integration like the word integration
it's about taking a whole bunch of
little bits and adding them together you
integrate them you take the song okay
which is why my notation actually has a
lot in common do it into it anyway what
about this guy the DX
what's a cold once it's what's its
relevance like if I changed it for you
suppose I change it to over do you
or D Y or a D theta what difference
would it make okay good so it's if
that's what variable one look for when
I'm integrating when I raise powers or
when I change the focus on okay so since
it's the variable that I'm looking it's
called a variable of integration it's
also called the differential but since
we're not differentiating that doesn't
make much sense in this context okay
now is one last piece that I'm after I
left it to last cuz it's the hardest one
that thing the thing you're integrating
you always never talk about it but I'm
sure some of you can know what it's
actually call it has a name know what's
the name of the function that actually
gets integrated it starts with annoying
well we already said that the whole
thing is the integral right and if I
took it but it's already here would not
be interval somebody's ready
just that function will do the whole
lesson because it's cold and let's go to
integrand okay now Murray so I went
through that whole lengthy process when
you think integration a lot within
functions okay there are two broad
categories of integrals that will land
you that have some connection to
logarithm functions okay and the two
categories are once where the integrand
is a log function and once where the
integrand is not but your primitive
would be a log function okay let me say
that again there are two broad
categories of integration type questions
that are related to Lourdes okay
the two kinds are once where the
integrand is a log function
once where it isn't okay so we'll start
with the ones where it is because I
think I think they're actually a bit
easier and they're the ones which you
will find on your table of standard
intervals so you could say non
logarithmic integrations I was gonna
happen is up in there in little F you're
gonna have an onload function but you'll
end up with a long function we integrate
okay so let's start off the easy one the
simplest one an old log function you
integrate it and you get a log function
what is it just the basic what an ass
good okay so that's just the natural
model okay we can extend it a little bit
coming because if you take this ID here
write whatever X we can do simple ones
that are very similar to this for
instance if I were to change it to
something like that's good let's do that
so I haven't changed all that much
okay so what if it does that three have
it's just a constant so in some senses
because it's convenient to me I can
write it now at the front it doesn't
really affect the president original
okay all right but what about the minus
1 will be X minus 1 what's going to
happen how's it going to face
okay story instead of Lorex I have to
have this is this is kinda versatile
isn't it the X minus one has to be
preserved on the right hand side so I'm
gonna have log off X minus one we've got
three is still hanging about plus your
cluster let's have a look at one more
and then we'll generalize it okay what
if I had something like okay what's
going on before you actually tell me the
answer what can we do to make the inter
a little more clear a little obvious to
us we do what are we looking for we kind
of what in this case right what we've
got is some function on the bottom and
it's derivative on the top right so
broadly speaking f dash on earth okay I
don't have f dash on F here but I can
with a little bit of twisty and turny
what should i do I should I should
multiply by 1/2 out the front which
remain I can put it to up here and
that's F - isn't it so I'll do that -
okay so just like before with that three
hang out the planet not really effective
integration that's not just going to
come out the front like so and it's
going to be
okay now I said we're gonna do our
example and then generalize I've already
mentioned it right if we have something
in the form F - or an F okay of which
whatever X is just a very special case
where F happens to be just the linear
function
if you're integrating that you're just
gonna get log off log of one just f plus
you're gonna get Tory cause they're
great